easy
Luka Modric
what was it about Luca
and then we got I remember we paid
against Croatia for England Stevie lumps
played
um you get this little guy Midfield I
remember just thinking wow this guy's
special
um just like so silky with a ball never
lost the ball could receive the ball in
anyone a pitch you just knew then that
he was going to be like um you know
world-class player then obviously a play
with him about Tottenham for a few years
again it just made the game look easy
everything went through Luca and
obviously a Ballon d'Or winner and
obviously everything they achieved at
Madrid it's just uh he's definitely one
of the best players I played with but
that's an easy one
Luca Modric